Jay Armstrong: I go to the psych ward. They were like,
"Mr. Armstrong, you've been here a ton of
times. What could you possibly say to us
to make us think you're serious about
staying clean this time?" And I was like,
"I'm not here to detox. I have a plan
to step in front of a train."
Justin Ponton: Well I found
myself at the Huntington City Mission,
homeless, on parole, completely addicted
to heroin.
Kelvin Young: I have a daughter. You know, she
seen me under the influence of heroin at a
public event and how I was so out of my
mind that I'd even actually urinate on myself.
My daughter seen that.
Justin Ponton: I went to my parole officer and I cried
to her and I told her, "I don't have
anyone left at all." She said, "You got me
JP," and she reached across the table and
she gave me a fist bump. All that
mattered was I at least I have one person,
and that gave me some hope.
Kelvin Young: It really
took me going to prison for the fourth
time to really do the inner work I needed to do, you know,
to find freedom. I'll never forget laying on
a bunk bed and saying to myself, "I needed to make some changes in my life."
Sally Satel: Recovery from addiction takes place in
basically two phases. The first phase
entails what I call stabilizing a
patient. This often, but not always,
involves medication. So the first step of
recovery is stabilization. At least the
person is standing still, working on
getting the rest of his or her life in
order. But then you have to draw the lens
out further. So you've got someone who's
stable, they're certainly not in
withdrawal, but their life isn't really
much better, and they don't see much of a
future for themselves, and someone like
that is at risk for relapsing.
Kelvin Young: So I took advantage of every single
program available while I was in prison.
That really helped me to deal with a lot of my
raw, human emotion that I suppressed
with alcohol and other drugs, and do the
inner work I needed to do in order to heal.
Matt Peterson: Once I got out, started working, met a
great girl. I was a cook at a really nice seafood restaurant.
Jay Armstrong: I've been doing stand-up for
just over eight years now.
I got into a kind of on a whim. I've
always wanted to do it.
Justin Ponton: After I got myself together and I got sober,
I developed and created a sober-living program.
Jay Armstrong: The thing about medically-assisted
treatment is that there are some people
that that is as good as it's gonna get
for them. I don't see it helping the
epidemic because these doctors that
prescribe it that's their go-to now.
There's no, "Hey, can we try to get this
person, you know, regular treatment first?"
Justin Ponton: Fortunately, the route that I was
given an opportunity to take did not
involve replacing one substance with
another. I don't want to just be
clean and sober. To me, that's... that's not
recovery.
Kelvin Young: One program that helped me the most
was a drug treatment program within
the prison. So after I finished the
program, they hired me to be a peer
mentor and helping other inmates that
was incarcerated with me to deal with
their recovery, and it gave me a sense of purpose.
Sally Satel: A very important part of
treatment and rehabilitation is getting
a person back to work. Work is so
important as therapy. It provides a sense
of purpose. It keeps people busy.
Matt Peterson: Well, I'm a full-time father. I work
full-time as a peer recovery specialist.
Kelvin Young: Today I'm a certified addiction recovery
coach.
Justin Ponton: My life is entirely all about
family and work.
Jay Armstrong: You know, everyone expected me to die a junkie's death.
But today I'm a productive
member of society. I'm a father, and I do
my best to try to lead those kids down a
way to where they know that they can
talk about anything that's going on with
them